let's talk about what's going on in new
york because as you guys know i was off
the grid for august and during august
andrew cuomo the governor of new york
had to step down because of all the
endless sex scandals that he was
involved in and when adam corolla
brought me back on the grid on september
1st i was actually shocked when he told
me because i really had felt that sort
of months had gone by and it seemed like
he really was going to skate free on any
of this stuff
as you guys know my feeling on
accusations of course are just that they
are accusations and unless there is
proof then just because someone says
something about you doesn't mean it's
true and we live in this endless cancer
culture thing which it's very dangerous
that we're all getting destroyed by
accusations in any event andrew cuomo
stepped down and before we show any of
the video of the new
new york governor kathy hoechel and this
woman is completely psychotic i want to
show you what i said on september 1st i
had never heard of this woman before but
this is when adam carolla told me that
andrew cuomo had stepped down
with lieutenant governor uh
but i'm gonna guess it's probably
somebody worse i assume is if someone
just like further left them yeah all
right so my guess on september 1st
without even knowing who she was is that
she probably was someone worse and
probably someone further
left now
i think i've been proven right we've got
a couple videos of governor kathy
hoechel who keep in mind nobody voted
for
she's firing hospital staff in new york
and replacing them with national guard
if they are unvaccinated so we went
quite literally from two weeks to
flatten the curve to a year and a half
later firing nurses in the name of
health take a look and we'll be nation
leading with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in the
hospital in the state of new york or
health care facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people uh who've been retired who
may have had a license lapse bring in
people from elsewhere that is not my
first position of my friends my my my
desire is to have the people who've been
out there continue to work in their jobs
working them safely and to all the other
health care workers who are vaccinated
they also deserve to know that the
people they're working with will not get
them
okay so just to be very clear about this
these are trained medical professionals
doctors nurses other people who work in
the hospital who've decided to make some
decision for themselves right they all
made a decision using whatever faculties
they have to figure out what's best for
them and their families these people i
think we've been told they are heroes
and they've worked very hard and they
put their lives on the line and
everything else this crazy woman this
authoritarian lunatic basically just
fired all these people at the stroke of
midnight again nobody voted for this
woman and i wish i wasn't correct on
september 1st about her being worse than
cuomo but obviously i was correct um but
if you think that's not bad enough that
she's saying to these people and just
wait even putting that aside putting all
of that aside if we're to believe
hospitals are crumbling and there's dead
people everywhere and i know we don't
see any videos of this right we don't
see overloaded morgues we don't see any
hospitals falling anywhere no village in
kenya has collapsed we don't see any of
it but they keep telling us it's
happening but if any of that was true
wouldn't you be saying you know what
we've got to keep the nurses no matter
what do they have any evidence please
i'm a guy of science can somebody point
me to any evidence of a doctor or a
nurse transmitting covid at a hospital
to an otherwise healthy person can
anyone show me that i'm guessing that
you can't but if you don't think this
woman is completely insane
now she's also telling us that the
vaccine is from god
i prayed a lot to god during this time
and you know what god did answer our
prayers he made the smartest men and
women the scientists the doctors the
researchers he made then come up with a
vaccine that is from god to us and we
must say thank you god thank you and i
wear my vaccinated necklace all the time
to say i'm vaccinated
all of you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants you know this
you know who they are
i need you to be my apostles i need you
to go out and talk about it and say we
owe this to each other we love each
other
jesus taught us to love one another and
how do you show that love but to care
about each other enough to say please
get vaccinated because i love you i want
you to live i want our kids to be safe
when they're in schools i want you to be
safe when you go to a doctor's office or
to a hospital and are treated by
somebody you don't want to get the
virus from them you're already sick or
you wouldn't be there
we have to solve this my friends
i need every one of you i need you to
let them know that this is how we can
get fight this pandemic come back to
normal and then start talking about the
real issues that we have to fighting
systemic racial injustice which exists
today and if there's a denier i will
take you on any day because i've seen it
i know it
you know when i was home in new york
last week i was chatting with my mom and
she watches the show every day she
enjoys the uh the reuben report program
that we do here but she said to me you
know uh david she calls me david she
said david you know you could
occasionally watch the language uh you
know you know you drop the f word every
now and again you can watch a language
with uh
you know sometimes on the show mom if
you're watching right now i need you to
pause this uh or mute it for just a
second
you got it mom that woman kathy hoechel
the governor of new york is a
authoritarian psychotic [ __ ] there's no
other way to put it like i don't know
how you can say anything how dare she
the way she's twisting god and religion
for her own political
motives it's actually disgusting and if
you don't think it's disgusting here's a
little more
from kathy hoechel
my default position is to ask people
please do this
this is why
it's been proven to be safe the
vaccine's been out there a long time now
there are not legitimate religious
exemptions because the leaders of all
the organized religions have said
there's no legitimate reason and we're
going to win that in court in a matter
of days
and so this is so unnecessary
and i just want to appeal to the
individuals to know that you know your
co-workers want you to do this
don't make the burden heavier on them as
well
guys your co-workers want to do it
someone else wants you to do something
so if you want to be a good person you
better do it and they're going to beat
the religious institutions in court i
mean there's an assault on religion too
which is a whole other topic although i
guess it's not that whole other because
it's happening right now in front of our
faces this is not a good woman